اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسيس
واشنطن وحلفائها بالسعي للتحكم في العالم
عبر فرض نظام القطب الواحد على الجميع ان
كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما مدى دقه حديث لابروف عن توجه
لبناء نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب ما هي
الدول المرشحه لتشكيل ذلك النظام العالمي
متعدد الاقطاب
فوجهت تحذيرات من امكانيه وقوع صدام عالمي
[موسيقى]
تتحدى ولكن روسيا اقتصادا لا يسمح لها ان
تكون دوله سوبر باور عظمى الصين هي كما
يقول دائما التقارير التي تصدرها الحكومه
الامريكيه سنويا هي اكبر تحدي للهيمنه
الامريكيه ليس عالما متعدد الاقطاب العالم
الثنائي للقطبين نتحدث هنا عن الولايات
المتحده والصين كلام لا يعتد به
روسيا قد تقدمت باعذار مختلفه لتبرير
الاعتداء على اوكرانيا تصحيح الخطا
التاريخي حول نشوء اوكرانيا الامن الوطني
الروسي
مساعده الانفصاليين في في دون باس دائما
روسيا تريد ان تقدم نفسها ان هي ضحيه
وتواجه الغرب وتواجه النيتو ولكن روسيا هي
التي هاجمت وهي التي غزت وهي التي تشن
حرفا على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
يعني هي دول بنايه الامر غير ديمقراطيه
وفاشله وليست نموذجا يتبع منحلفاء روسيا
بنهايه الامر يشكلون هذا التعدديه القطبيه
بالنسبه لروسيا كوريا الشماليه نيكاراغوا
سوريا كمحاوله الحديث عن الاستعمار الغربي
الاستعمار الفرنسي البريطاني مثلا
لافريقيا نعم روسيا لم تستعمل في افريقيا
ولكنها استعمرت في اسيا الوسطى وفي
سيبيريا والصين كذلك لم تستعمل في افريقيا
ولكنها استعمرت في التيبات واستعمرت في
تركستان الشرقيه ونشهد ما يجري اليوم طبعا
حتى المصطلح هو غربي يعني ملفت للدول
الناميه التي تريد ان تتحرر من النفوذ
والهيمنه الغربيه ولكن بنايات الامر يعني
القدره محدوده هو تثقيل لهذه الدول وارسال
رساله لامريكا بالدرجه الاولى ان عندنا
خيارات اخرى من الخطا اعتبار بريكس وكانها
اعاده انشاء لكت له مواجهه للغرب
بالشكل الذي كانت عليه الكتله الاشتراكيه
ليس هذا هو الواقع المعظم اعضاء البريكس
هم في البريكس للتنويع وليسوا في البريكس
للحصريه
[موسيقى]
يعني امريكا هدفها الاستراتيجي هو منع
تحالف روسي صيني يكون هو يعني المحور
الرئيسي لنظام متعدد
ياتي في اطار ترويجي محض اي انه لا يمكن
ان يعتاد به ولكن الاعلام الموالي لروسيا
غالبا كان افريقيا تنتفض على الاستعمار
واقع الامر بان عندما نتحدث عن انتفاض
افريقي هنا بعض الانقلابات العسكريه غير
التي لا يمكن وصفها على الاطلاق بانها
حركات شعبيه على اي حال الامريكان نفسهم
يتكلمون اننا نحن متجهين الى نظام متعدد
الاقطاب مالتي بولر وهذا النظام يشمل صعود
دول تراجع امريكا كقوه عظمى يعني بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه كانت امريكا تنتج
50% من مجمل الناتج القومي العالمي الكلي
الان تنتج اقل من 25% اي القراءات
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه للواقع المقبل هي
باننا نشهد صعودا للصين تريد الولايات
المتحده ان يكون صعودا هادئا وان يبقى في
اطار النفود الاقتصادي والا يصرف عسكريا
مقابل هبوط لروسيا